[Music]
austin is in atlanta georgia hi austin
welcome to the ramsey show
hey guys appreciate your time sure
what's up
hey i was calling uh mostly about a
career question
i was recently
i've been in ministry my whole life i
recently laid off
as many people during the pandemic
trying to get myself back out there i've
kind of got a limbo job i would say to
pay the bills now
um but from asking all my friends and
everyone else in ministry it doesn't
seem like
the money is quite there like it is
everywhere else in the world and what i
mean by that is like you know
everything's getting so much more
expensive but it seems like ministry
jobs are actually paying less
um so i was trying to see
should i keep pursuing this that is
really my passion or should that more so
be my side gig being your all-star
volunteer
and maybe going more into the workforce
to help provide for my family
this is an interesting question austin
because there's
there's more to this
than just the financial equation
because of what you're asking about
and so i'll i'll tell you something i'm
kind of uh i'm i'm learning right now
austin and this is just from from very
recent for me so i'm in seminary right
now and i'm taking a class right now on
practices and vocation formation and it
talks about how different people are
called
into ministry called into different
aspects of serving and there's a
there's a very
pretty consistent correlation where
people are called into ministry they
feel called in different capacities in
different ways um and they're called
because of the they they pursue that
they're obedient to that because of the
calling not because of the
um compensation
and
and you need to pay your bills
but i don't think that you can look at
this
question you're asking from purely
uh
just a financial lens because because of
the the faith aspect of what you're
saying
um right you know if
if you if your question is
um you're always gonna make less in
ministry yeah that
that can't be the reason you go or don't
go because that's just that's just a
given of the industry now the other
thing is this
there's um
really the last hundred years or so is
the first time in the history of
christianity
uh that we've looked at professional
ministry as the only people doing
ministry
prior to that everyone was in ministry
meaning that the blacksmith did his job
as unto the lord
the uh the restaurant owner did their
job as under the lord and the way they
treated people and the way they did
marketplace interaction was a ministry
they were ministering through their
business and through their uh vocation
without being quote professionally in
the
pastorate
there's nothing wrong with being
professionally in the past obviously
some of my best friends in the world are
that
but the uh uh
but this idea that the only people that
serve god or that are in ministry are
on a church staff is a fairly new idea
uh right
and and so uh you know
the jewish mindset is the word worship
and the word workship are very similar
words of worship service on
sunday morning and customer service on
monday morning both are a service
in both cases we're having a service
so
we view what we do here very much as a
ministry
as believers and um
[Music]
some agree with that some don't but
that's not relevant to this discussion i
it's what we do and it's who we are so
uh it may be that you are
uh you know you're being released from
vocational ministry to do ministry
in the marketplace so to speak with
wherever you land i'm okay with either
one if you feel like you have a solid
call on your life to be in vocational
ministry to be on
you know church staff
then you're going to make less
my contemporaries that run a
40 million dollar budget
at a church
make
probably 50 60 percent of their in
of the income of someone who runs a
comparable-sized business
and so it's not that unusual at all so
it just kind of goes with the territory
and it's not not that it's right or
wrong but it just is
i think you bring up a good point though
because i one of the the challenges i
would have for you austin is as you
reflect on this and you think about this
and you pray about this
ask yourself
am i am i have i always been in ministry
and feel like i need to be in ministry
because that's my heart my passion
because i feel called specifically to
that
method of ministering in the church
world for example or
do i feel like i need to do that type of
work because to me that represents
somehow good work that somehow
represents work that makes a difference
and the
secular world the for-profit world
represents bad work work that doesn't
really help people a lot of people get
these mixed up and dave you and i have
talked about this when it comes to
business non-profit versus for-profit
there are people that believe
that non-profit organizations are more
holy
than for-profit organizations to them
that represents a a different value and
worth and and it's so interesting dave i
mean i learned all of this from you but
i the the non-profit for-profit
designation is a tax status it's how the
money flows to the organization nfl the
nfl is a non-profit organization
so we so i would just encourage you
austin as you're reflecting to think
what am i
pursuing is it good work because you can
do good work in the church and outside
the church you can change lives in the
church and outside the church
or is it i feel called specifically to
being on church staff like you said dave
and that's a different that's a
different question just know that you
you will make less if you do that which
is fine we need people in the pulpit we
need people in churches um and god's
calling your life i really believe he'll
provide for you but but just make sure
you're not pursuing it because you think
somehow that's the only way to do good
work i believe that every one of us here
at this organization and many other
organizations um non-profit or
for-profit are doing good work that
changes lives so that might be a good
exercise for you to reflect on as you as
you think about this yeah good question
sir thank you the other thing that was
in his he said you know i wonder if i
just volunteer it's kind of made me
think his heart is
is already gone he's moved on and he's
ready to ready to have another phase in
his life so what it sounded like when
there's permission for us to to change
seasons i think sometimes we are so
resistant to let go of something we
don't recognize it was a season we think
everything's forever
and so i remember when i when i felt my
heart being done serving in young life
ministry in the day-to-day with
teenagers at high schools i wrestled
with that for probably a year too long
my heart had already moved on but i
couldn't let go
that this was what i was supposed to be
doing and now we support young life in
other capacity but everything isn't
forever it might just be a season
and you have permission to change your
mind and change your plans and move into
this new season yeah and on the other
subject it is a good to remind everybody
here's the thing there's no such thing
as a non-profit organization
a nonprofit organization that doesn't
make a profit is closed
they always take in more than they have
go out
it's just how they it's just an
accounting function the irs does not
decide if something's holy or not
and they do decide whether something's a
non-profit or not based on the
guidelines that they have
and so but a non-profit that's not
profitable
closes they go broke
just like a business does
so this idea that somehow they don't
make a profit is asinine
this is the ramsay show